Whenever any movie is released, there are
bound to be some people that like it, and
others that don't.
After all, beauty is in the eye of the beholder,
and art is almost always subjective.
A film's popularity is usually just a matter
of taste and timing, but every once in a while,
a film's very premise can turn people off
at the outset.
In the case of these movies, the stories had
some people so enraged that they wished the
movies had never even been made.
Caligula
Some films are created by great artists who
are inspired by a grand vision for a work
of art that can inspire humanity to higher
ideals.
And then there's Caligula, the brainchild
of Penthouse's Bob Guccione, who essentially
convinced the world that the picture was going
to be high art, only to pull a bait and switch
and turn it into an all-out sexcapade.
Given his history as an adult magazine magnate,
it's probably not surprising that the film
has some risque [risk-AY] action, but what
was surprising is how much skin is shown throughout
the film.
"It has an irresistible mixture of art and
genitals in it."
The fact that it stars great actors like Malcolm
McDowell and Helen Mirren, and was written
by Gore Vidal is also something of a shock
when you see it because while the stars and
writer thought they were making the next great
historical epic, Guccione secretly shot a
bunch of hardcore scenes to splice into the
film during the edit.
The result was so shocking that the rest of
the cast and crew revolted, and the film was
banned.
Vidal had his name removed from the film altogether,
and the actors were allegedly furious.
"It's such a mish-mash.
There's some wonderful stuff in it, and some
absolute garbage."
The Last Temptation of Christ
As an adaptation of the 1955 book of the same
name, Martin Scorsese's The Last Temptation
of Christ already had a legacy of controversy
before it was even filmed.
The novel, from Greek author Nikos Kazantzakis,
infuriated the Greek Orthodox Church and inspired
religious protests upon its publication.
So it probably wasn't much of a surprise when
the same groups rose up against the production
of Scorsese's film.
What was surprising, however, was how broad
the resistance had become, as some Catholic
and evangelical Protestant communities joined
with the original Greek Orthodox Church in
their condemnation of the film.
So, why did Last Temptation draw so much pushback?
The film portrays Christ as a human figure
wrestling with his own divinity, wracked with
various temptations like lust, fear, doubt,
and anger.
The titular "last" temptation involves an
extended sequence during which Jesus renounces
his divinity, marries, and has children.
Though Jesus later rejects the possibility
and sacrifices himself, the very fact that
the religious icon was presented in such human
light was rejected by the church masses.
United 93
Coming off the success of The Bourne Supremacy,
director Paul Greengrass chose to turn his
attention to a real-world tragedy, the events
of September 11th, 2001.
His film, United 93, went into production
in 2005, just a few short years after the
largest terrorist attack in U.S. history.
With America still involved in two wars wrapped
up in the resulting War on Terror, the film
was primed to set off strong reactions — and
it did.
When the trailer for the film was first shown
in theaters, it sparked outcries of protest.
People accused Hollywood of callously cashing
in on the horror of that day, without any
regard or respect for the people directly
affected by it.
The backlash was pronounced enough that distributor
Universal had to publicly announce that they
would not be pulling the trailer from movie
theaters, although the studio did agree to
donate ten percent of the opening weekend
gross to a 9/11-related charity.
Fortunately in this case, the finished film
allayed concerns of a crass capitalization
of tragedy.
Reviews were glowing, and family members of
victims found United 93 to be respectful to
the memory of those lost.
But it also became an example of a film with
genuine artistic merit that had to weather
initial doubts in order to at last be embraced
as a triumph.
Watchmen
Once upon a time, comic book superheroes were
for kids.
They wore brightly colored costumes, fought
bad guys, and always did the right thing.
By the mid-'80s, though, a number of comics
presented a darker, bloodier, more adult look
at heroes and their worlds, and one such was
Watchmen.
The series was written by Alan Moore and arrived
as a brilliant deconstruction of the entire
superhero genre that showed the flawed humanity
underneath the spandex.
Watchmen was a project he'd created for industry
titan DC Comics, which was itself owned by
film studio Warner Bros., which meant that,
at any time, WB could take his creation and
turn it into a movie.
After the success of the comic adaptation
300, WB gave the rights to Watchmen to director
Zack Snyder — and Moore was furious.
Calling the very idea of a Watchmen movie
"regurgitated worms," Moore insisted that
his work was intended exclusively for the
comic medium and was never intended to be
adapted into anything else.
"It might entertain people for a few minutes,
but I'm not interested in it because it's
not the story that I was trying to tell."
But his protests fell on deaf ears, and Watchmen
arrived in theaters in 2009.
When it did, Moore's name was nowhere to be
found: he had himself removed from the credits
and even rejected any share of the film's
profits.
The Interview
Seth Rogen and James Franco have made quite
a few successful films together, including
Pineapple Express, This Is the End, and The
Disaster Artist.
But their 2014 political comedy The Interview
was met with the kind of pre-release backlash
apparently no one in Hollywood expected.
The screwball comedy featured the two as a
pair of idiotic talk show producers contracted
by the CIA to take out Kim Jong-Un.
It's not the first time a North Korean dictator
got spoofed on-screen, of course.
"Why aren't more people intelligent like me?"
But this time, Kim fought back against the
film's release.
The isolated nation doesn't receive a lot
of Hollywood exports, so its so-called "supreme
leader" might have seemed like a safe target.
However, Sony underestimated just how much
offense the dictator would take at the film's
release.
He reportedly ordered a cyberattack on Sony
Pictures, which led to the leak of a trove
of embarrassing emails.
While the email leak was bad enough, the hackers
later threatened violent action if the film
was ever released.
Facing a PR disaster, Sony pulled the film
from theaters, a decision criticized by President
Obama.
"I wish they had spoken to me first."
However, in defiance of the dictator, The
Interview was almost immediately made available
on streaming services, so it was still entirely
possible for audiences to watch Franco and
Rogen carry out their plot against a fictional
Kim.
Slender Man
Most of the time, internet memes are meant
to be good-natured distractions from the malaise
of modern life, but when the Slender Man trend
came along in 2009, it was anything but fanciful
fun.
As the viral myth grew from one creepy picture
to the next, the character inspired some disturbed
teenagers to commit terrible crimes in real-life.
So, when Sony Screen Gems decided to turn
the internet fad into a film, a lot of people
were not happy.
The father of one of the attackers, for example,
protested the film for being a sensationalist
cash grab, and a petition was even started
to halt the film's release.
Despite all that, though,the film is currently
still slated for a fall 2018 debut, at which
point audiences can judge its merits for themselves.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!